Vanessa Bryant and her daughters are
getting into the Easter spirit starting
off the celebrations a day early Vanessa
shared a sweet video over two youngest
daughters Bianca and Capri trying to
break open a large Easter egg as they
find the hidden treats inside the
festive age Bianca and capris reactions
are priceless the mama for captioned it
Easter treats Bianca and Capri this is
the first Easter Vanessa will celebrate
with her family since her husband Kobe
Bryant and their 13 year old daughter
Gianna died in a January helicopter
crash God knew they couldn't be on this
earth without each other babe you take
care of our chichi and I got 90 BB and
cocoa we're still the best team the 37
year old has been sharing heartwarming
videos of Kobe and Gigi like this one
started out playing soccer which is one
of my favorite sports as well but then
when she asked about learning the game
of basketball then
I started teaching her piece-by-piece
and she started enjoying it and loved it
now she please every day Coby talks
about coaching his daughter and the
happiness it brought him it's been a joy
to watch her grow
[Music]
in the clip Kobe says Gianna is a good
mix of both him and Vanessa which makes
her even more competitive than the Laker
legend competitive very fiery and backs
down from no challenge
vanessa has also continued to speak
proudly about Kobe's accomplishments he
taught us all valuable lessons about
life and sports through his MBA career
his books the show detail and his puny
x' podcast series we're so thankful he
let those lessons and stories behind for
us she recently got emotional in an
interview after her late husband was
inducted into the Basketball Hall of
Fame incredible accomplishment and honor
and we're extremely proud of him sitting
with her oldest daughter Natalia vanessa
fought back tears as she praised Kobe
obviously we wish that he was here with
us to celebrate but it's definitely the
peak of his NBA career and an every
accomplishment that he had as an athlete
was a stepping stone to be here
[Music]